welcome to this video this is a new
video about one of my over the board
games and um ya understand that you you
like those so I'm doing doing more and
I'm actually with this video with this
video I'm i will have done a video on
all of my games that I played them this
year in in higher level competition and
we had this this game in fact hem this
video is from the Dutch league placed in
the Meister class of the first leaked
and known and the Netherlands um one
thing to note is that for my other
videos that i have uploaded the bomber
over the board games one part of it
always was the preparation now try to
think about beforehand what to play
against an opponent trying to look at
their games and so on in the dutch
league this is pointless because you
play obviously it's a team competition
against an opponent against an intern
opposing team and one of those players
you will play but you never know which
one before hand so you can theoretically
speaking look at like five six seven
different players and prepare in each
case something against them but it's
pretty much pointless so I never prepare
anything and most players are don't ya
don't do as well so we just sit sit down
at the board you know five minutes
before the game who you play and then
you go let's start this I'm black
playing as auto Piper's out of purposes
a young dutch player 19 or 20 years old
geez rated to 372 38 is something like
that I should I should have looked it up
earlier but it's around this release
range slightly below to form yeah we got
a 45 if I don't know something specific
or have no specific idea in mind I'm
playing the playing the classic
stuffy five and we got a way with 983
the absolute main line yeah here I'm
playing I'd a high of the Chi Goren
Quincy 792 96 I'm doing the opening here
really quickly because the game gets
really hot later and yeah it would be
yeah sort of wasting lots of time to
talk about some some moves that have
been played a ton of times yeah this
knight c6 line in the chi Goran it's one
of those lines that I have learned when
I started to play a 45 is black and it
sort of sticks with me like a bad habit
I always think that I should look at
something else there something more
active like let's say the Brier or some
other line in the in the main line Roy
besides things like the Marshall attack
and stuff that there are some slightly
more active lines the main worry for
black he is actually d 598 and this
closed position I recently uploaded a
blitz video where I lost this line
against Graham master loosed amorphouse
black I was ok but lost at the end yeah
here my opponent played a different line
he played d take c5 and he played this
quickly really if we had this on the
board like after two minutes or so
really quickly yeah he took on c5 are we
captured and yeah what about this line d
take c5 is this main line probably not
d5 nowadays the closing of the center is
considered to be wide space ever since
the game cup of wounds ago which in fact
I also covered just recently on my
channel
the same variation is featured in this
law in this said this game yeah the
capture on c5 however has a has a really
huge stamp of approval because it was
Bobby Fischer's favorite move Fisher I'm
like to exchange on c5 and he did this
in a number of games the main point the
main idea of the captures that black has
weakened to the d5 square with this d5
with his a5 and c5 set up and very often
Fisher would manage to get a Knight to
g5 this kind of night maneuver can be
very rewarding it is a very a very
viable set up and to be honest this is
one of those cases I always thought that
I should look at this line a bit better
a little bit more to know it really
because I always felt like I I have
insufficient knowledge and it was held
really bad that he played this year and
I was thinking okay I should have looked
at this earlier not for the specific
game but yeah and some other games like
blitz games I always felt like I don't
really know what's going on there okay
he went a 4 which is a bit uncommon as I
learned afterwards I wasn't really sure
from him um the main movie m is night
everyone and tonight everyone is
actually what Fisher played all the time
there is a very famous game Fisher with
white against calm off rocked me a coma
I'm played in known in Havana 65 this is
actually the game that um yeah solo yet
I knew the game and do you would see in
the
in the actual game that I played against
purpose that I lend some idea from this
game yeah this was played in this column
of game fish are being wide very nice
nice g5 black just place age six and
let's white capture this point is
controlling useful squares and after be
four which is not good really calm of
played the brilliant move 94 sacrificing
a piece and here he got huge play with
those pawns and won a great game against
Fisher and this is basically the only
thing that I knew that these kind of
ideas are are in the position and yeah
this is really not a good preparation
for for a game of this stature okay he
played a form and I went Bishop e6
Bishop belongs there I guess anyway yeah
I want to place my pieces in a way that
d5 is covered he went 95 ok i am
reckoned with this and i went back to
the seven and i didn't really want to
allow the capture on e6 it does not feel
like this is so um yeah so viable here
as it was in the end official calm of
game so I wanted to preserve this Bishop
I wasn't keen on this devil porn he
played nine f1 which is pretty normal
you want to get the night here to f5 or
like here to f5 there are various routes
to this or of course as I mentioned
earlier night to d5 here so this is all
pretty normal I went look to the eighth
which threatens some discovery so this
movie some very much to be expected aged
69 f 3 and ce4 yeah black really wants
to do this to see form it has some more
than one idea grab some space possibly
there is some an outpost on d3 yeah if
we look at this like bishop here and
then the light might jump all the way c5
g3 and so on so this might be useful
and it also prepares what happens later
in the game as a possibility of course
the Bishop to c5 also can be an idea
yeah he went night age for this
surprised me a bit but it's not a band
really um in an in an earlier game in
them from the 60s um somehow i lost the
exact game reference in my in my notes
one of the players was borislav scheme
there in the 60s there was a game where
a takes be 580ex be five night at straws
played and then rupee eight which easily
it could have happened in our game we
didn't have from the the trade on b5
happening and so okay night ash was not
not a bad movie i'm okay i went through
create and here we come to the first
absolutely critical position of the game
um here my opponent took took some
moments and then played night III and
this move by looking fairly innocent or
normal is in fact a pretty substantial
mistake and it is a mistake because he
misjudged there now coming complications
and he see saw my reply of course
because it's the total standard move but
he misjudged what's what's happening
afterwards yeah what should he have done
i mean one thing is maybe do the same
thing that happened in this in this
earlier game as mentioned like this and
maybe queen a free and tending night f5
this looks like a totally normal
continuation in this old game night h7
was played not so not a bad idea
possibly intending this or maybe 95 and
also an idea in this type of position i
think you can argue if this is a slight
edge for white or black heads equalize i
mean i don't really mind that position
very much i think black should be okay i
don't have
a bad piece and he does not have a huge
attack or anything but arguably maybe he
is a bit more a bit more comfortable now
I'm not totally sure down but this is
what he probably should have done the
move Knight III as mentioned here looks
totally normal but it has a huge problem
and this is of course the move Knight
deform which are played and relatively
yeah fred is right if converted quickly
because I was anticipating that night
you free i'm going to do this and I was
only briefly checking it then it went
for it and this is in fact now I'm
another interesting of an additional
interesting point here with 94 this
piece sacrifice that white has to take I
mean he cannot move the Queen it's not
cannot go anywhere here and step give up
the bishop and so on this is terrible so
white as white takes and I recaptured
and when I played 94 I had calculated
this a couple of moves ahead like to
move 25 or 26 now we are no one moved to
anyone and my every problem was that and
once I had decided to play 94 I was
playing the the subsequent moves really
quickly here I thought that night e to F
5 is basically the the critical move and
do that white should play um it turns
out that here wyd probably should have
played 'if I've yeah by this is a move
that the computer is giving after
something like this the the engine gives
black a pretty clear edge but it is some
I mean it's two pawns for the piece but
I have a huge center and there's always
be three coming so this is pretty good
for black but it's still better than the
game because in the game white is
basically lost I mean
this is really like that he went 92 f 5
which was the only move that I really
considered because everything else looks
like very easy I mean it looks like bad
and it's easy to play and evaluate so
this was what I'm really expected yeah
okay I took this of course and Wendy
three all played quickly so i was just
playing playing out the line that I had
envisioned and now he went queena three
after some thought um that's really yeah
basically the only move what what else
what else is there he can take on his
seventh first but this exchange is a
strong attacking piece so it cannot
really be be that great in something
like that for example yeah it's playable
for white or you can do that it's not
helping it much in fact it's funny that
the computer does not even want to take
here he wants to just advance the pawns
and and claim that this porn roller is
much more dangerous than than any piece
yeah black is almost almost winning them
yeah he went to f3 which is clearly the
the move to play yeah and now we come to
the point where um where I'm I'm simply
doing something extremely stupid I mean
it's really the only only way to to
describe it in when I looked at the
night vision to this position while
playing 94 of course I needed to to look
look this far my train of thought was
all right now I'm an excellent shape
because i'm going to play d to ya with
the fork he will take it what else rook
takes I'm taking this bishop and I'm
threatening Bishop c5 with the huge play
against against this so it should be
fantastic for black and if he goes 'if
I've this was my my my idea if he goes
'if I've i'm going to play Bishop c5
yeah and he's got still F 2 and c2
and he cannot take on f6 my idea well I
cannot take because II one is hanging
and I just can take it the problem is
the look on you want is protected by the
a1 rock at the beginning of the whole
line if we go back to 94 look look at it
here here the rookie one is unprotected
there is no connection here between the
rocks on the first rank so I thought I
had this in mind Luca is unprotected and
I just played this line out like like in
a black and blitz game right and here
and here and he 5 and this was played
and here was thinking out Bishop c5 and
I'm winning and but why why is he one
protected all of a sudden the problem is
simply I I had a head in mind that with
the unprotected rook I can play Bishop
c5 but I cannot the problem is if I go
Bishop c5 he's just going to basically
basically kill me out with the rooks
protected he can take on f6 11 possible
line is for example takes takes takes
takes poop Stidham and check and black
can resign this is only this is the most
spectacular one but it's not like I'll
overlook this or whatever I was simply
simply believing he 5 is impossible
because II one is he cannot take f6 and
if for some weird reason this move was
forbidden I would be winning instantly
almost yeah but I was I was simply not
not rechecking my calculation I was just
playing this D to move instantly and
this is especially especially idiotic
because instead I could have taken of
course this Bishop on c2 and this is
leading to a position where black has a
huge agents almost winning the computer
at least is on more than
one porn+ white has to be extremely
precise to even stay as stay in the game
the problem is that this pawn is
existing on c2 and it's not easily
captured there is Luke t1 at some point
and let's say rookie 2 rookies one and
resins this kind of things and I have
pressure against this with Quincy 6
coming well White has no really serious
counterplay I'm covering those critical
squares and let's say he goes Bishop f4
if we want to continue this line because
this is really gap the logical
continuation here Bishop h6 looks
dangerous okay but i have i have a
counter play and the counter players is
far more problematic Bishop to c5 now f2
is a huge problem black here is really
winning yeah it's not like a natural
something black is winning here because
white is falling apart on e4 on f 2 and
so on yeah Queen g3 for example I just
go g6 and nothing's happening and its
really yeah it's really a shame I am
after Queen f3 I just need to take on c2
and this is the result of this this nice
idea with Knight d4 but yeah well as i
mentioned i played d2 and yeah
immediately and i also immediately
recognized what what what went wrong he
played d5 and i was thinking oh my god i
cannot play Bishop c5 yeah and the thing
is if I cannot do that what what am I
playing this night is attacked and um
yeah hmm it's not like I have excellent
squares mmm I decided to go to d5 then
after I had some more calm down a bit
after this initial shock I went to not
hear of course I went to d5 yeah I
didn't look much at 97 because II six
already looked like terrible but
the analysis supported with the computer
even reveals that 97 Queen g3 is almost
a direct win for white something like
Bishop g5 for example to block is
answered by h 4 and this this leads to a
total disaster and it's a quite funny
line though if we want to look at this
ruki five at first this does not look
that terrible but g6 is exceptionally
strong the idea is that that this is
quite nice yes very nice made yeah
assume this is shauna echo blemish balm
smartwatch design I have a huge problem
to to do it in English yeah he took on D
to e 5 and yeah went to d 597 it's not
playable so I went to d5 and I was
really thinking oh my god I'm going to
get checkmated here it really should be
that I'm that I'm not surviving this the
problem is look at this he's got this
fantastic night on f5 the huge taking
piece the bishop is is on the Kings side
okay it is hanging by the rook yeah it's
a tech by the rook but still it's part
of the attacking force and he always has
moves like Queen to g4 Queen 2g 3G 6 I
mean it looks terrible I was really
thinking okay yeah I'm going to play a
couple of more moves and I will probably
get checkmated now however however it
turned out that it's not that easy very
very strangely enough it is not that
easy my opponent now took a long time he
was a little bit down on the clock
anyway but he now thought for quite a
long time trying to find ya a knockout
punch and it is it's really it's really
amazing he didn't find any men
the problem is there is no one hundred
percent total killing continuation it
really looks like there should be one
but at least in my computer supported
analysis I didn't find it there is more
than one line that looks fantastic but
it's not yeah it's not like simply
winning or anything um one problem is
that I let's say I will need to rephrase
this there was one line that we both
calculated where we made a very clear
misjudgment um and this is Queen g3
certainly something that we both looked
at Queen g3 I was thinking um while he
was pondering his decision that I can
play g6 in this position as bad as it
looks I know that I can play g6 in this
position because Knight takes h6 which
was the only move that I considered
really King g7 is surprisingly not clear
if he now sacrifices I can take the
bishop yeah and then the tech is
basically over this isn't that clear he
can give a check here of course but I
just move the king and it's not clear
that I'm losing his night is hanging his
Bishop is hanging this is not convincing
at all we both looked at this what we
however both overlooked is and I think
that Queen g3 for that reason um yeah I
don't know I know maybe I would have
seen this but 96cm is winning for white
really winning there is no no escape
there it is a fantastic position now for
four white the rook is attacked I have
to take this piece ed6 tempo on the
Queen and the pawn is of course
protected and supported by the Queen on
g3 and this turns out to be impossible
to play like this why it is going to
sacrifice
the aid and going to kill me totally
white wins does this mean that Queens
III would have won hmm maybe it would
have won in the game because I'm yeah I
would have played g6 very likely very
likely the funny funny and very strange
thing is after Queen g3 black in fact
has a defense that looks totally totally
a moronic but it works it's not losing
black can play the the absolutely
horrible looking new g5 and it is
believe it or not the computer is not
giving why the win here I'm you know
it's very very much possible if you look
at it at your home with your computer
and you take even more time than i did
that you find a win or the conference
win because it really feels like a
matter of let's say justice yeah that
black should lose this but yeah what
what can i do i mean i didn't find a win
here yeah the computer wants to take
which yeah makes sense rookie d1 is also
possible but check here Bishop before
where the bishop is still hanging and
night f4 this is one funny point of g5
it gives the square on f4 for the night
and this is a totally messy position
that at least the computer is only
giving a slightly better for what I'm
really amazed I cannot really explain
this but somehow somehow this is a more
resilient position than you would think
um twinge III was was a very interesting
try and those moves are the reason why
he burned his time and another
interesting move and maybe the strongest
one maybe um yeah did it it was it was
afeared strong of course at 24 also they
didn't play that but also interesting
the ideas the direct kill with checking
and entering with the Queen or some
97 it also of course covers the bishop
yeah I would have played Bishop c5
giving me some some some roommate for my
king and then it's it's quite remarkable
this move looks looks killing at first
because yeah wins the house but I came
to kill here and this is surprising
enough not not clear white can play this
gather the Queen Queen iya and I'm
taking on f2 yeah going for counter play
all of a sudden and it is really strange
but after this the situation is not
clear it's really not I mean it's a
total mess and the computer is not
giving white anything yeah I don't know
it's it's really strange um he however
in this line has a better he can take on
g7 yeah this is better than taking on
edge 7 because now in addition the rock
is subject but even that I mean it looks
like I'm residing in the next couple of
move is not totally clear I can take on
f2 th1 and now the move Knight to f6
yeah 98-94 97 I think what's my line 97
check check and takes on c2 and believe
it or not this is again not not really
totally clear yeah White is of course
better but even this is not like a total
kill um very weird very weird um I
actually believe that the the best move
if we go back is night to d6 this is
also what we had analyzed right after
the game when we were reviewing it
together without any computer assistance
this was our conclusion that 96 is the
best and it should lead to a wide edge
and without
any huge complications big point is if i
take it which looks very normal he will
of course recapture and now we have this
situation here rook hangs and the Queen
hangs and whatever I do I will be in
some trouble I can take only one for
example and go here and now white as a
has a simple continuation more than one
actually but if we start with this yeah
it cannot really take on c2 sd5 is
saying and this is more important but
this and now I'll move like that and
tending d7 this is this is very
uncomfortable for me or alternatively
there's also the move route d1 which is
interesting you are giving up this by
taking this for the deep on YT is better
just just better um probably after 96 a
tougher defense is some remarkably look
f8 which I don't know if I would have
played that I really don't know Queenie
for is quite logical why not threaten
meet and then I have to play g6 with a
prior it looks it looks amazing that
that black should survive this okay and
if we continue rook t1 is a good and
simple continuation the sacrifices are
not winning but rookie one is good for
white let's say take and night before
take something like that cuz it's just a
good position for whitey as the
fantastic night here on d6 and is in
command so somewhere here probably is
the continuation that would have
punished me for my reckless on d to move
iam what did he play he played not 96
here in this position he made a yeah
really a mistake in calculation he
played Bishop eform and it turns out
that after that y term is again in huge
trouble is really a new trouble the
problem also was that after the move he
only had very little time left here was
basically burning on his time to find
her to find a mate or a total KO and I
didn't find it yeah and then went for
Bishop before and the problem is it is
really no a tightrope walk on a
tightrope for white because i have
Bishop c5 now and i played this
relatively quickly because i want i want
this counter play and I wanted him to to
to have little time to reflect Bishop c5
looks like the best move anyway it still
looks very dangerous or this this attack
but the the problem is that he went
Queen g4 and this definitely loses the
only move that keeps the fight going is
the quiet move king edge one which is
not exactly obvious to a to a human
player um after that the best move is
rook takes you five quite strange but it
is the best move and funny enough after
King edge one something like this is not
even not even that clear yeah something
white hands has tons of tons of tactics
going going for him oops with the with
the fork oops with a fork yeah and the
best one after King edge one would have
been rookie five not a very intuitive
move to be honest but this is the best
um a takes be if we continue the the
main line a takes be I'm sorry King h1 I
am I made a mistake in not look f two
queens III rookie fathers made on g7
taking here of course I'm sorry taking
here of course yeah after that as much
even the same applies rookie five is not
exactly an intuitive move um yeah and um
what should should whiter why do now
after rupee five they are probably
taking on b5 and will now take here and
here i have the funny resource rookie
takes a five because here my night is
protecting my queen quincy 797 and now
probably this Bishop f5
Bishop f5 a b5 I need to take take the
pawn first if I do this this is getting
getting too much oops sorry I'm this was
a this was a bad miss click where was
the critical position here a b5 rookie 5
Bishop before something like that and he
a black is better with two pawns for the
exchange but it's a it's a totally am
yeah totally open fight let's say um
it's a very theoretical thing to look at
this because well he had no time no time
and yeah I had some some minutes and 30
minutes 20 minutes or something but um
with this complicated position you never
knew what what could happen King edge
one was some what's the toughest by far
he went Queen g4 and lucky for me that
he went with this because well he had
little time and when I had looked at
Bishop c5 I had calculated this pretty
pretty okay because I thought that ok
Queen g4 is not working because mmm yeah
I can really just take it I can take the
pawn in the middle of the board and with
this I'm covering covering here and it's
it's really amazing why it has no
attacking continuation here that is some
convincing if he takes on d5 for example
I will grab f2 and e1 and he really has
no decisive attack something like this
I'm going to just go to evade here and
that's it white only had a check yeah
I'm surviving him and on your dad I'm
winning and what else is there he took
on age 6 yeah this is certainly making
some sense ok king of eight nothing else
no and now he took on f7 with really no
second one second on the clock here
needed to to play our move yeah and here
and black is winning in more than one
way it's still
messy but the pain main point is f2 it's
just hanging with with the bishop I
could have taken this with the bishop
booth check but the move that I had seen
is also winning i played Queen f4
getting out of this attack and sold off
yet it's a move that lets everything
yeah White has all hanging all pieces
are hanging now the other the f7 night
potentially yeah I note that I couldn't
have taken this yeah this is we've been
really bad idea or Bishop g5 and this is
this is good we need the Queen resize
enough so as mentioned Queen fos what I
played and here really he has no move
and just before I could could get loose
on time he decided to take here after
which I can exchange trade Queen's note
that he has no check in this position h
takes G Bishop have to check King moves
and that took the rope here yeah and now
a black is totally winning the night is
sorry the bishop is attacked on d5 and
his bishop yeah my bishop also needs to
be taken first so something like that is
just a rook in exchange and this night
is also trapped so really tragic game
for my opponent in a way because um yeah
I was I was really doing something
extraordinarily stupid by playing d2m um
simply I was trusting what I had thought
of earlier and was just um just going
for that I didn't really recheck or
anything I just played this um while I
was relying what I had seen when I
played 94 and yeah this was really
stupid taking on c2 is a is really just
good for black and with d2 I I really
was deservedly in huge trouble however
it still amazes me that that
96 seems to be the the key move and it's
not leading to a direct win maybe if you
invest even more time in analyzing you
find the direct when I wouldn't be
surprised at all but we both agreed
after the game that there should be some
some killer blow but we didn't yeah when
didn't see it in the game we didn't see
it in the analysis and even the computer
is not like blinking wildly and says
minus 3 or something we didn't we didn't
stop there maybe there is a win but the
lines that I am I was showing to you
they yeah they were good for white but
it's not like you're you're meeting
black instantly and surprisingly really
really surprisingly so um yeah this is
one of those cases where you you can
apply this saying it's better to be
lucky than good yeah I mean I was really
lucky here that this mistake didn't then
cost me the game immediately this is
calculation error and in fact that i
want this rather quickly afterwards was
a felt a bit like a miracle during the
game okay i hope you enjoyed this it was
was a fun ride and probably a game that
you could have yeah analyzed and
presented in a much longer form but want
to keep it in within a reasonable
reasonable length this kind of videos
hope you liked it thanks for watching